[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und marietta slomka
abend im moment stehen die zeichen eher
wieder auf sturm und damit ist an dieser
stelle nicht die meteorologische lage
gemeint zu dir kommen wir später sondern
die weltpolitik im konflikt mit russland
saß anfang der woche ja eher nach naja
vorsichtige entspannung aus aber jetzt
wird die tonlage wieder scharf us
präsident biden hat erneut erklärt er
befürchte einen russischen einmarsch in
den nächsten tagen im osten der ukraine
gab es beunruhigende gefechte deren
hintergründe im einzelnen noch unklar
sind außerdem hat moskau neue
forderungen an den westen gerichtet und
nebenbei den amerikanischen vize
botschafter ausgewiesen das sind
ziemlich viele ungute entwicklungen
florian hand berichtet
wer als us-außenminister hier vor einem
krieg in der gegenwart warnen will der
muss erst mal kämpfen gegen den schatten
der vergangenheit
sicherheitsrat der vereinten nationen
new york vor 19 jahren hieß der us
außenminister colin powell das regime
vor dem er warnen sollte saß im irak die
von paul vorgelegten beweise aber waren
falsch sein nachfolger anthony blinken
sagt heute das sei nicht zu vergleichen
ich bin mir bewusst dass manche unsere
informationen in zweifel ziehen weil sie
an frühere begebenheiten erinnern wo
unsere erkenntnisse sich nicht bestätigt
haben aber lassen sie mich klar sagen
ich bin heute nicht um einen krieg zu
beginnen sondern um einen krieg zu
verhindern
es geht um die ukraine wo heute an der
frontlinie wieder gefechte gemeldet
werden wo jede seite die andere
beschuldigt und wo schon ein kleiner
zwischenfall an den großen krieg
auslösen kann auch heute steht erstmal
aussage gegen aussage auf der einen
seite russland das wieder bilder
veröffentlicht die an den abzug von
truppen und gerät zeigen sollen und
dessen regierung jede kriegs warnung als
westliche hysterie abtut auch in new
york wir werden nicht zulassen dass sie
diesen ort nutzen für ihre aggressiven
wort verrenkungen dass wir angeblich
vorhaben die ukraine anzugreifen
auf der anderen seite der versammelte
westen heute etwa bei der nato in
brüssel der russland seinerseits
eklatante lügen vorwürfe
bewiesen das gegenteil dessen was sie
sagen in den letzten 48 stunden haben
sie ihre truppen um bis zu 7000 soldaten
verstärkt nehmen sie beim wort aber wir
werden sie an ihren taten messen oder ab
kenntnis was also tut russland rückzug
oder aufmarsch beim preisgekrönten
recherche kollektiv wellink at studieren
sie hunderte truppen videos aus sozialen
medien satellitenbilder ihr befund
bislang ist eindeutig
russlands behauptung eines truppenabzugs
ist irreführend wenn nicht komplett
falsch wir sehen ungefähr dieselbe zahl
von soldaten die sich weg von der grenze
bewegt wie hin zur grenze es scheint als
hätten diese bewegungen vor allem ein
ziel verwirrung zu stiften
verwirrung stiften um einen krieg zu
beginnen im sicherheitsrat beschreibt
der us aussenminister wie russland einen
vorwand für krieg schaffen könnte das
können sie ein fingierter
terroristischen bombenanschlag in
russland sein die entdeckung eines
erfundenen massengrabes in der ukraine
ein vorgetäuschter drohnenangriff oder
ein falscher oder sogar echte angriffe
mit chemiewaffen
es ist eine warnung wie die welt sie in
dieser krise noch nicht gehört hat einig
sind sich beide seiten heute nur darin
die lage sei gefährlich
sondern mit unseren korrespondenten noch
vertiefen schon zunächst nach washington
mrt wissen joe biden hat jetzt erneut
vor einem einmarsch in den nächsten
tagen gewarnt das gab es schon mal dann
passierte es aber nicht wie wird diese
dringlichkeit von der us regierung
begründet
die lage schätzt man hier als wirklich
sehr sehr ernst ein so hören wir aus dem
weißen haus das hat mit drei punkten zu
tun der erste ist eben dass die zahl der
soldaten noch einmal deutlich erhöht
wurde er innerhalb von 30 kilometern zur
ukrainischen grenze entgegen der
versprechungen zu beginn dieser woche
zum zweiten eben mögliche fords fleck
operationen also inszenierte gewalttaten
um damit einen vorwand für den krieg zu
bekommen da gibt es weitere hinweise
über die russische medien die staatliche
verbindungen haben eben in den letzten
tagen auch berichten zum beispiel ein
angebliches massengrab im osten der
ukraine und das dritte und das ist
glaube ich das wichtigste hier im weißen
haus ist die antwort aus moskau
eingegangen auf die vorschläge der nato
und die des us präsidenten und das wird
ja als sehr sehr klare absage gewertet
denn innen drin steht im chromium wenn
man das durch liest dass man die zeit
zurückdrehen will auf das jahr 1997 als
der kreml ja mit der nato reine grund
akte verabschiedet hat das würde
bedeuten dass selbst so starten wie die
baltischen staaten die nato wieder
verlassen müssten dass man nato-truppen
aus osteuropa wieder abziehen müsste
also der kreml bleibt bei seinen
maximalforderungen erklärt dass zu einem
gesamtpaket aus dem man nicht einzelne
teile herausbrechen kann und das wird
hier im weißen haus sehr klar als signal
gesehen das ist eine eskalation geben
kann und der präsident rechnet damit
schon in den nächsten tagen
schauen wir mal perspektivwechsel nach
moskau zu unserem kollegen christian
semmeln diese neuen maximalforderungen
wie immer eben sagte die russland da
erhebt warum tut putin das wie wird das
von beobachtern in moskau
eingeordnet
ja das ist die klare ansage dass moskau
derzeit an einer kompromisslösung unter
den bedingungen nicht interessiert ist
sonst wäre man ja konstruktiv auf die
vorschläge der amerikaner eingegangen
das nicht passiert im gegenteil die
maximalforderung die wurde ja sogar noch
einmal erhöht obwohl man hier auch ganz
genau weiß dass das natürlich nicht
erfüllt werden kann und das klang vor
zwei tagen klangen das ja auch ein
bisschen anders als bundeskanzler scholz
hier war da war viel von dialog die rede
da hat sich wladimir putin l
pressekonferenz ja auch schon auf die
vorschläge der amerikaner bezogen hat
gesagt das ist nicht die antwort die wir
hören wollen aber sind doch ein paar
punkte dabei über die man das notieren
könnte und davon ist jetzt heute nichts
mehr zu hören das ist natürlich dann
punkt der hier der hier kritisch gesehen
wird und dazu kommt auch noch die
beunruhigende lage an der grenze gibt
verwirrung über den truppenabzug sind
sie jetzt wirklich abgezogenen teilen
wir sind sogar noch neue dazu gekommen
und dann heute die beunruhigenden
meldungen aus der ost ukraine dass es
neuen beschuss gibt auch wenn man da die
details noch nicht kennt weiß man dass
das natürlich ein pulverfass ist und
dass die lage da sehr leicht eskalieren
kann in einer region in der die menschen
schon seit jetzt fast acht jahren unter
dem krieg leiden allerdings dankeschön
für diese einschätzungen aus moskau und
washington
und wir wechseln hat das thema und gehen
nach deutschland
der sogenannte wohnungs tag ein großer
branchentreff heute in berlin befasst
sich zweifellos mit einer der größten
gesellschaftspolitischen
herausforderungen unserer zeit das
wohnen ist sozial frage und betrifft
zugleich massiv den klimaschutz in der
mehrheit sind wir noch weit davon
entfernt klimafreundlich zu wohnen im
gegenteil der umbau wird allerdings
kosten zugleich braucht es vor allem in
den städten bezahlbaren wohnraum
sozialverträglich und klimafreundlich
und das alles auch noch möglichst
schnell wie soll das gehen das habe ich
robert habeck gefragt der ja gerade mit
der kürzung von fördermitteln für viel
empörung gesorgt hat doch zunächst ein
bericht von sylvia bleßmann
diese platte hat potenzial einem über 50
jahre alten ddr bau des typs wbs 70
werden nochmal drei stockwerke aufs dach
gesetzt das pilot projekt einer
städtischen wohnungsbaugesellschaft will
zeigen dass auch mit aufstockung
sozialer wohnungsbau möglich ist
experten aus politik und bauwirtschaft
erfahren dass hier zwar keine neuen
grundstücks kosten anfielen aber man vor
vielen anderen problemen stand
es geht los bei der ertüchtigung der
fundamente im keller schon da beginnen
die ersten herausforderung für die
bieter wir würden sehr gerne in den
sozialen wohnungsbau auch in holz
vorantreiben da haben wir mit enormen
kostensteigerungen zu tun die müssen wir
den griff bekommen insofern ist es für
mich fast alternativlos wir werden
sozialen wohnungsbau auch auf den
dächern in unseres bestandes werden
weiter entwickeln durch den umbau von
altbauten könnten allein auf
wohngebäuden 1,5 millionen neue
wohnungen entstehen weitere 2,8
millionen über büros oder läden
insgesamt 4,3 millionen neue wohnungen
vor allem metropolen wie berlin müssen
in die höhe bauen verdichten und um
nutzen der anteil von grund und boden am
gesamtpreis liegt bereits bei 45 prozent
explodierende baustoff preise und
wachsende klima standards sind ständige
kostentreiber die regierende
bürgermeisterin hat wohnungsneubau zur
chefinnen sache erklärt und fordert auf
dem wohnungsbau tag eine gesunde balance
zwischen sozialen und ökologischen
interessen
es ist notwendig dass wir bei allem was
wir an standards setzen ein was wir
fordern auch ökologischer nachhaltigkeit
das da genauso auch die frage der
bezahlbarkeit und der sozialen
verträglichkeit gestellt wird und
vielleicht muss man nicht immer 100
prozent aller wünsche erfüllt bekommen
um auch ein gutes ziel zu erreichen
neben deutlich mehr umbau setzt die
bundesregierung auch auf mehr neubau ein
aktueller kosten check zeigt jedoch dass
der neubau am teuersten ist gefolgt von
modernisierung ausbau und aufstockung am
günstigsten ist der umbau von
bürogebäuden in diesem neuen
wohnquartieren bei den hellersdorf
konnten nur mit kfw fördergeldern
bezahlbare wohnungen entstehen gelder
die dann teilweise gestoppt wurden die
baubranche fordert langfristige
verlässliche förderkriterien die
regierung ist unter druck neben zufolge
bin ich dabei habe ich heute auch
angekündigt eine zweite milliarde für
den sozialen wohnungsbau auf den weg zu
bringen auch mit dem e h 55 standard
auch mit blick auf das klima der staat
wird tief in die tasche greifen müssen
um die ehrgeizigen wohnungsbau ziele zu
erreichen
für die förderung von wohnungsbau der
zugleich klimafreundlich sein soll ist
der bundeswirtschaftsminister zuständig
guten weg hallo guten abend ich wurde
heute auf dem wohnungsbau tag ja
sicherlich auch noch mal gesagt wie
unerfreulich die branche das fand dass
sie die fördermittel für
energieeffizienten wohnungsbau so abrupt
gestoppt haben konnten sie denn da eine
erfreuliche perspektive bilden oder wie
geht es da jetzt bitten oder wie geht's
weiter also erstens das war unerfreulich
keine frage das geld verschlingt alle
und die kreditanstalt die kfw bank
durfte nicht weiter auszahlen nachdem es
keine geld angaben der stadt kinder
keine gelder versprechen die nicht im
haushalt bereitgestellt sind das war
also eine vollbremsung und sicherlich
ein schock für viele und ja es gibt eine
perspektive die weitergeht wir haben die
also die bewilligten oder die gestellten
anträge werden jetzt bewilligt und die
sanierungsförderung also bestehende
häuser klimafreundlicher machen die
läuft ab nächster woche wieder an und
das folgeprogramm wird auch zeit mal
wieder aufgelegt aber sie wollen ja die
standards erhöhen also diesen
ermittlerin standard den man bisher
hatte den soll es dann nicht mehr geben
sondern es soll noch klima effizienter
gebaut wenn das problem ist ja dass
bauen immer so irrsinnig langen vorlauf
hat auch bis dann mal anträge auf
förderung gestellt werden hat das ein
wahnsinnig langen planungsvorlauf da
stehen jetzt sogar
schadensersatzforderungen an sie im raum
also wir wollen die standards erhöhen
wir haben auch weil das programm davor
so teuer war noch eine milliarde
bereitgestellt für neubau programme die
werden aber auf einem höheren standard
sein und da muss man sich auch
klarmachen dass die milliarde schnell
weg sein kann wir werden es anders
machen als jetzt davor es gibt also kein
enddatum kein kalendarische
beziehungsweise ende des jahres haben
wir ein neues fördergesetz dann und eine
neue förderung klar aber diese eine
milliarde steht zur verfügung und die
wird dann über höhere standards für
ausgabe werden mit einem geringeren
fördersatz und ja so eine milliarde sage
ich da ist könnte ein tropfen auf dem
heißen stein sein wenn man weiß dass
allein schon die sanierung machen die
kann nach wenigen wochen wechseln das
ist ja ziemlich viel richtig aber die
sanierung auch als der neubau kostet
viel von effizienten häuser und die
sanierung auch eine nennen verbände
große zahlen 50 milliarden dann
millionen in den nächsten jahren bis 25
wie soll das aufgefangen werde man doch
gleichzeitig ein wohnungsbau auch will
der bezahlbar bleibt indem man eine
trennen rechnung an stellt was der staat
fördern sollte ist das was nicht
standard ist also die ökologische
wertigkeit die klimafreundlichkeit im
baum da haben wir jetzt in den letzten
jahren ein ständer jahren erlebt es gab
eine überförderung deswegen sind die
gelder so stark belebt gewesen und er
sollte den sozialen wohnungsbau fördern
und damit die preise günstig machen
gerade für die menschen die es nicht zu
dicke haben das haben wir in der
vergangenheit ineinander geschoben und
deswegen ist die klima förderung auch
kofinanzierung des sozialen wohnungsbaus
genommen wurden das trennen wir jetzt
und die kollegin klara geywitz wird über
das bauministerium einen großen pot
auflegen eine milliarde haben um den
sozialen wohnungsbau zu fördern und wenn
der auch noch klimafreundlich ist dann
kommen noch die gelder aus dem klima
ministerium obendrauf jaja
klimafreundlich zu bauen das müsst ihr
ein anliegen gerade auch der grünen
seien dann auch wenn von co2 bilanzen
beim bauen spricht da ist viel holz bau
gilt dann als daisy hat aber ich habe
letztens ein handwerker witzeln gehört
die dachlatten das ist das neue wissen
die neuen goldbarren war einfach die
kosten so in die höhe geschossen sind
das ist eigentlich nicht mehr möglich
billig zu bauen oder noch billig zu
vermieten also die baukosten sind enorm
nach oben gegangen sprunghaft zusammen
mit den energiepreisen eigentlich und
vor allem im holz ist das so tatsächlich
ist es so dass dachlatten im moment der
goldstandard sind im baum das liegt an
der hohen nachfrage global nach
rohstoffen und an spekulation in den
märkten und gerade beim preis also bei
der sozialen frage im bauen gar nicht
jetzt bei meinem ressort der klimaschutz
aufgabe sondern bei bezahlbaren
wohnungsbau der ja viele menschen für
viele menschen nötig ist und viele
menschen umtreibt die muss man sagen
dass auch in den letzten jahren enorm
spekulation reingegangen ist also sehr
viel geld angelegt wurde und dadurch die
preise getrieben wurden
spekulation ist das eine aber eben die
baustoffe das andere habe das ist ein
breites feld also allein die
altbausanierung da könnte man eigentlich
nur eine halbe stunde
wie man heizungen umstellt aber wir sind
hat heute an einem tag wo auch noch das
weltgeschehen und es hier rein fliegt
etwas brachialer übergangen aber mit
blick auf die ukraine wir haben sie am
anfang der sendung gehabt wie sehr
befürchten sie dass dieser konflikt
jetzt wirklich eskaliert sie sind ja
vizekanzler auch dieser regierung
ja ich hoffe dass das nicht passiert
aber man muss realistisch sein und sagen
so eine massierung von truppen haben wir
in den letzten jahrzehnten nicht gehabt
so eng aufeinander stehend und wir haben
ja eigentlich eine ein krieg in der ost
ukraine schon die ganze zeit der ist
etwas still gestellt gewesen aber leute
sterben da und auf die wird geschossen
und es bedarf nur eines funkens um aus
einer angespannten situation jetzt einen
massiven konflikt zu machen und wenn
dieser funken auch noch geschürt wird
wenn also provoziert wird wenn ein
vorgehen an dem tag kommt wo man
verdeckte aggressionen macht um daraus
dann aggressiver akte abzuleiten dann
kann das sehr schnell bedrohlich werden
also die ganze bundesregierung und ich
auch persönlich wahrscheinlich alle sind
hoch alarmiert was wiederum heißt dass
die diplomatie alle anstrengungen
unternehmen muss diese situation zu
deeskalieren sagte deutscher vizekanzler
habeck danke für das gespräch ich habe
zu sagen
und damit kommen wir zu dem sturm der
durch deutschland fegte und er war wie
angekündigt heftig damit beginnen die
nachrichten von hanna zimmermann
orkantief lenia hat zu chaos und
hunderten einsätzen von feuerwehr und
rettungskräften geführt drei menschen
sind ums leben gekommen darunter ein
autofahrer in niedersachsen bei bad
bevensen bei einer landstraße stürzte
ein baum auf sein auto in hamburg
zerschlug eine welle die frontscheibe
einer hafen fähre drei passagiere sollen
dabei leicht verletzt worden seien und
bei der bahn viele zugausfälle wegen
entwurzelter bäume aber auch als
vorsichtsmaßnahme im norden hatte die
bahn den fernverkehr vorsorglich
eingestellt und
es bleibt stürmisch ab morgen nachmittag
zieht bereits das nächste orkantief
durch die nordhälfte deutschlands an den
küsten dann stellenweise mit extremen
böen mit bis zu 160 stundenkilometern
mehr dazu später im bett hat
man hat ihr amt als neue us
botschafterin in deutschland angetreten
am mittag hat die 72 jährige
politikwissenschaftlerin von
bundespräsident steinmeier ihre
beglaubigungsschreiben erhalten goodman
hat deutsch jüdische wurzeln und ist die
erste frau auf diesem posten
fast zwei jahre war dieser unbesetzt
grund dafür eine blockade der
republikaner im us senat
frankreich will seinen
anti-terror-einsatz in mali beenden als
grund nannte der französische präsident
mag die zunehmenden konflikte mit der
militärregierung in dem
westafrikanischen land auch die
bundeswehr ist in maadi stationiert sie
beteiligt sich dort an einer eu
ausbildungsmission und ist außerdem teil
einer un-friedenstruppe beide mandate
laufen ende mai aus ob diese einsätze
ohne frankreich fortgeführt werden
können ist laut verteidigungsministerin
lamprecht noch ungewiss
die frage nach dem mali einsatz der
bundeswehr wird uns in nächster zeit
sicher noch beschäftigen und ein
größeres thema werden doch insgesamt ist
dem schatten der pandemie und der
russland problematik der afrikanische
kontinent für viele hier in europa etwas
aus dem fokus gerückt zu unrecht denn
was in afrika geschieht betrifft uns in
so vieler hinsicht unter anderem bei der
pandemie bekämpfung bei migrationsfragen
investitionen rohstoffen und was vielen
vielleicht nicht so sehr bewusst ist
beim thema klimawandel
einer der schwerpunkte beim zweitägigen
eu afrika gipfel in brüssel über den
auftakt berichtet gunnar krücke
bei diesen bildern ahnt man es nicht
doch dieser gipfel will weg von den
klischees afrika brauche europa klar
aber auch umgekehrt brüssel sorgt und
sendet heute die botschaft so viel
augenhöhe war nie
[Musik]
wir brauchen keine anweisungen wie wir
uns zu entwickeln haben wir wollen nicht
ausgeschlossen werden wir wollen mit
europa eine neue partnerschaft begründen
der gipfel heute ist der erste
meilenstein ich liebe die vision dass
zwei kontinente hand in hand arbeiten
für eine bessere welt
dafür müssen die europäer ihren gästen
schon etwas bieten investitionen etwa
von 150 milliarden euro auch für
klimaschutz für afrikas energiewende
länder wie südafrika wollen kohle noch
ausbauen die eu möchte stattdessen für
europa in afrika wasserstoff produzieren
die energiepartnerschaft zwischen europa
und afrika ist von zentraler bedeutung
und das was wir vor uns vorgenommen
haben mit erneuerbaren energien ist
gleichzeitig eine
entwicklungsperspektive für viele länder
afrikas für viele aber nicht für alle
stichwort anweisungen
afrika ist nicht verantwortlich für den
klimawandel unser anteil an weltweiten
co2 ausstoß ist nur vier prozent der
kontinent ist nicht industrialisiert
also kann man von uns nicht fordern auf
fossile energien zu verzichten
auch im kampf gegen cupid 19
gegenseitiger abhängigkeit und streit in
afrika liegt die impfquote bei 11
prozent
südafrika baut darum m rna impfstoffe
nach haltbarer und villiger die deutsche
biotech schickt dagegen impfstoff
fabriken in den senegal aber die patente
nicht frei deutschland bleibt dabei hat
viele afrikaner auch
es wird ein großer erfolg aber wir sind
bereit darüber hart und lang zu
verhandeln der streik blockiert den
gipfel und der eigentlich größte ist nur
am rande thema afrika will legale
migration europa die rücknahme von
menschen ohne bleiberecht projekte wie
dieses in ghana bringen sie wieder in
arbeit das ziel der europäer dass viel
geld auf den afrikanischen kontinent
investiert werden sollte damit eben
flucht erst gar nicht stattfindet
migration gesundheit klimaschutz europa
interessiert sich nur in wellen für
afrika in konkurrenz mit anderen ist das
zu wenig
mit dem blick auf die deutsche
wirtschaft macht anna weiter die zahl
der privatinsolvenzen hat sich im
vergangenen jahr fast verdoppelt man
könnte meinen wegen der korona pandemie
aber so einfach ist die erklärung dann
doch nicht weil die halle an der
frankfurter börse woran lag es genau
also schon krone hat schon auch dazu
beigetragen aber weit mehr ins gewicht
fällt tatsächlich etwas anderes und das
ist eine gesetzesänderung die führte
neue fristen ein ja und seitdem dauert
das insolvenzverfahren statt sechs
jahren nur noch drei betroffene können
nun also viel schneller von ihren
restschulden befreit werden und diese
änderung die haben bestimmt einige
abgewartet mit großem einfluss auf die
zahlen seit jahren gehen die
privatinsolvenzen zurück nun im jahr 20
21 die wende erstmals seit zehn jahren
entwickeln sie sich sprunghaft nach oben
und verdoppeln sich im vergleich zum
vorjahr sogar nahezu dieses jahr könnte
es aber noch schlimmer kommen nach
einschätzung der auskunftei schlagen nun
die wirtschaftlichen folgen der pandemie
stärker durch sie rechnet weiter mit
vielen privatinsolvenzen wichtiger grund
die menschen stoßen zunehmend an ihre
finanziellen grenzen nach pandemie
bedingte arbeitslosigkeit oder
kurzarbeit sind die reserven
aufgebraucht dazu kommen steigende
energiepreise und mieten geschätzte
privatinsolvenzen dieses jahr
110000 und damit noch mal etwas mehr als
20 21 diese schätzungen der experten
gehen zwar auseinander dass aber auch
dieses jahr wieder mehr menschen privat
insolvenz anmelden müssen davon gehen
die meisten aus danke valerie nach
frankfurt
es ist ein rekordgewinn für airbus und
das trotz corona krise der flugzeug und
rüstungskonzern hat
2021 einen überschuss von 4,2 milliarden
euro erwirtschaftet und zwar vor allem
weil das unternehmen so viele
verkehrsflugzeuge verkauft hat aber auch
weitere sparten wie hubschrauber rüstung
und raumfahrt lieferten gute ergebnisse
zur europa league im hinspiel der
zwischenrunde hat borussia dortmund
gegen die glasgow rangers verloren mit 2
4 unterlag der bvb vor 10.000 zuschauern
im eigenen stadion
das rückspiel findet kommenden
donnerstag in schottland statt und
entscheidet ob die borussen ist doch
noch ins achtelfinale schaffen
nach dem s bahn zusammenstoß bei münchen
ermittelt die polizei jetzt gegen einen
der lokführer der 54 jährige habe
vermutlich ein haltesignal überfahren
sagte die staatsanwaltschaft am montag
waren die zwei züge auf einem
eingleisigen streckenabschnitt frontal
kollidiert dabei kam ein mann ums leben
die beiden lokführer und vier weitere
menschen wurden schwer verletzt
der journalist und autor peter
merseburger ist tot er starb am dienstag
im alter von 93 jahren in berlin
merseburger war von 1967 bis
1975 leiter und moderator des
politmagazins panorama am ersten
außerdem arbeitete er viele jahre als
ard korrespondent der fernsehjournalist
war eine der prägenden personen der west
deutschen medienlandschaft
das war's im heute-journal bei maybrit
illner geht es gleich ums geld unter dem
titel preisschock nach der pandemie ist
der wohlstand in gefahr diskutiert sie
unter anderem mit christian lindner und
friedrich merz
und gegen 0.45 gibt es dann unser
heute-journal update darin spricht wulf
schmiese mit dem präsidenten der
architektenkammer des landes
rheinland-pfalz joachim rinnt über die
wohnungsnot und wir beide sind morgen
wieder da bis dahin wiedersehen tschüs
[Musik]
guten abend es ist eigentlich ganz
typisch dass die stürme bei uns gleich
in serie kommen nachdem tief wie lenia
das ja jetzt heute über uns
hinweggezogen ist kommt hier gleich das
nächste tief hinterher das formiert sich
gerade über dem atlantik sein name ist
xenapp es liegt noch westlich der
britischen inseln bringt aber sehr milde
luft mit und zieht in den nächsten 24
stunden über den ärmelkanal weiter in
richtung dänemark es bringt viel regen
mit und wieder orkanböen es ist
allerdings sehr schnell unterwegs heute
nacht ist es meist ruhig nur an den
küsten von nord- und ostsee gibt es
nochmal stürmische böen hin und wieder
kann es ein bisschen regnen oder es
fällt etwas schneeregen die temperaturen
sinken auf 7 bis 0 grad und morgen wird
es sehr mild im süden baden württembergs
und bayerns steigen die werte auf 14 bis
18 grad sonst bleibt es bei sieben bis
13 grad kühler morgen vormittag sehen
sie noch die sonne jetzt zwischen der
ostseeküste dem erzgebirge auch in
süddeutschland wird freundlich vom
westen aber kommt dass die sehne heran
bringt regen mit und der erreicht am
nachmittag dann auch den osten dann geht
es kräftige schauer und gewitter hier im
westen und eben wie der orkan böen
schauen sie sich hier die situation
morgen abend gegen 19 uhr an dieses
windfeld wird im laufe der nacht weiter
nach osten ziehen es bleibt also einfach
sehr stürmisch am samstag verlässt uns
das sturmtief aber wechselhaft und
windig geht es weiter genannt